تيك توك تحول في الاونه الاخيره الى قضيه
عامه دوليه وشعبيه
بين الولايات المتحده والصين باتت تيك توك
قضيه امن قومي وصلت حده تهديد واشنطن بحذر
المنصه لكن خلف الكواليس من هم الرابحون
والخاسرون الفعليون
وفقا للصحيفه
مثل هذه الخطوه في الولايات المتحده يمكن
ان تتسبب في رد فعل عنيف من بعض
المستخدمين الذين يرون في التطبيق جزءا من
هويتهم لا سيما المراهقين والشباب فيما
يخشى اخرون ان يؤدي الحظر الى موجه من
ردود الفعل المماثله من دول ضد النهج
الامريكي حيث بالامكان ان تمنع تلك الدول
بدورها شركه التكنولوجيا الامريكيه التي
تنشط على ترابها الى جانب تاثيرات المنصه
القويه على المعلنين والانشطه والشركات
التجاريه التي قد تواجه خسائر ضخمه في حال
فقدانها تيك توك
لكن ما يشكل خساره للبعض قد يتحول مكاسب
لاخرين في حال حضرت امريكا تطبيق تيك توك
ستخلو الساحه الرقميه لمنافسهم خاصه انه
مع ظهور منصه تيك توك والمزايا التابعه
لها حاولت منصات اجتماعيه اخرى تقليدها
بطريقه عرض المحتوى لكن رغم ذلك لم تحظى
بالشعبيه واسعه والارقام كانت خير دليل
كان مستخدم انستجرام يقضون 17 مليون و600
الف ساعه مشاهده يوميا مقارنه بقرابه 197
مليونا وثمانمائه الف ساعه يقضيها مستخدم
تيك توك
بين مخاوف امنيه وخسائر ماديه ومعنويه
وفوائد منافسيه هناك مخاوف تطال المحتوى
هم اباء المراهقين الذين يشعرون بالقلق من
التعرض ابنائهم لمحتوى لا يتناسب مع كافه
الاعمار التي تستخدم المنصه والذي يجادر
كثيرون بانه محتوا يفتقر للرقابه الكافيه